je m'appelle gérard mouton et nous avons
écrit un livre avec virginie des mots de
l'amour qui s'appelle maupassant sa
passion pour château page 11
gérard mouton et kato vient il adore sa
ville de château et son riche passé
artistique il découvre l'oeuvre de
maupassant à son adolescence et en est
imprégnée il admire son génie page 12
virginie demel l'amour et kato viennent
elle est sculpteur et professeur de
sculpture à chatou
guy de maupassant est un écrivain de
génie qui est né en 1850
il a écrit énormément de récits il a
écrit trois cents nouvelles plusieurs
romans il était journaliste hausse il a
écrit plus de 1000 chronique
en fait il a découvert chatou à l'âge de
23 ans pour faire du canotage et c'est
devenu sa passion il est venu très
régulièrement et à chatou il a eu des
amis peintres des amis écrivains
il a eu beaucoup d'amour de coeur aussi
et c'était sa vie entière ses meilleurs
moments il les a passées à château page
chatou est donc très présente dans son
oeuvre littéraire dans sa nouvelle ça
ira maupassant écrit que de souvenirs cv
hier brusquement mois chatou le
restaurant fournaise les longues
journées en yole au bord des berges 10
ans de ma vie passée dans ce coin de
pays
sur ce délicieux bout de rivière on a
découvert qu'il était ami avec renoir et
ça c'était
extraordinaire donc renoir venait très
souvent lui aussi à chatou il y a peint
le déjeuner des canotiers deux grands
génies qui sont donc connus dans ces
quelques mètres carrés ici ou hameaux
fournaise
[Musique]
oh
on
page 66 renoir connaissez maupassant
voilà ce qu'il écrivait à propos de lui
un joyeux drille j'avais sympathisé avec
guy de maupassant cet écrivain passionné
par l'eau et le canotage cela ne
l'empêchait pas d'être mélancolique de
voir tout en noir
nous n'avions rien en commun il voit
tout en rose disait-il deux mois on
s'accordait sur un seul point
maupassant est fou disait jean riant
renoir et foum rétorquait-il en me
donnant une bourrade amicale sur
l'épaule
[Musique]